[inaudible]
joining me today is the founding editor
of Colette clearly made welcome to the
Rubin report.
Thanks Dave.
Thanks for having me.
I am thrilled to finally have you here.
This has been like what,
87 years in the making, right? Yeah.
Well I live a very long way away,
so it's difficult for me to get here.
Yeah, well you made it, you
made it thousands of miles.
You are part of what I would
say is IDW Australia, I suppose.
Spora yeah, exactly. Um, okay, so there's
a ton I want to talk to you about.
Obviously I want to focus on Colette
and the work that you're doing and we
obviously have a lot in common on the
issues that we care about and things of
that nature. But first off,
you are from Australia.
I've only had I think a two other guests
that are Australian natives on the
show. Yeah. What's going on
in Australia these days? What,
what does the rest of the world
need to know about Australia?
I would say that in Australia were
pretty chilled out at the moment,
at least politically and
culturally compared to America.
And even Europe to a large
extent, we have a, we've had, um,
25 years or more of economic growth.
So people are pretty relaxed.
People are doing well, the
middle class is doing well. Um,
there's not so much of a feeling that
is a zero sum competition going on.
Like people are fighting over
scarce resources and you know,
we obviously have political
correctness and identity politics. Um,
a lot of that's being
imported from America.
Yeah.
And how does that get imported?
Because I was mentioning to you right
before we started that a disproportionate
amount of our patrons, the people who
support the show or Australia. Yeah.
So even if things are going pretty well,
there's definitely a segment
of people that are going,
something's either not right or
where we're seeing the science.
That's something coming.
Yeah, it's true. I mean,
it's difficult to identify exactly how
these cultural trends get imported. But,
um, for example, through
universities, through social media,
through traditional medium,
so similar narratives get picked up
by journalists like the oppression,
narratives and, um, and
we're seeing with the,
with the young,
younger generations how they're,
how they pick up ideology through social
media and through the echo chambers and
the filter bubbles that are so
easily accessible. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you think that there's a geographic
reason that some of this stuff hasn't
fully hit Australia yet?
I mean,
being surrounded by water and
a place from the rest of us,
there's probably a little bit of
safety in that I would imagine.
Although borders are changing
just because of technology.
Yeah. It's um, yeah, so
we are more isolated,
that's for sure. Where smaller.
Um, so we don't have the same,
we're not as diverse as other places
like Europe and the United States.
Um, we have less income
inequality in Australia,
which makes a difference. And, um,
well we're actually kind of
parochial as well. I mean,
we do pick up cultural
trends from America,
but at the same time we just focus on
cooking shows and reality TV and football
games.
Yeah.
So when the article came out back in
was it may or so the renegades of the
intellectual dark web,
you were included in there and many
of us had not even met you. Yeah.
This is actually our first
time meeting in person. Yeah.
Even though we've been
chatting online for awhile. Um,
were you shocked about the reaction to
that article because it really did sort
of level up all of the issues
that we've been all talking. Yeah,
no, no, I wasn't shocked at all.
I think that the general movement,
this ideas movement and
this push back of the,
the sort of moral orthodoxy that the
politically correct left have at the
moment.
It's been brewing for some time and
someone just had to put a label on it.
Someone just had to name it.
And um,
I wasn't shocked by the groundswell of
reaction to it because I've been seeing
it through my work with Colette.
There are just so many people who
write to me every day who say,
I love what you're doing. I can't,
um, write a blog myself account,
put my name on it because I would get
in trouble at work or in my university
where there are so many people who,
um,
want to participate in these discussions
but can't for whatever reason. And um,
you know,
they liked it to be now be able to
put a label on this general movement.
Yeah. So tell me a little bit
about your personal background.
What led you to be one of
the people that is okay.
Putting your name on this stuff because
I do think that's one of the huge issues
here. Yeah. We get all this
support from academics. Yeah.
Even people in politics and, and regular
folks who were like, yeah, I'm with Ya.
And I see the dangers, but I don't
want to put my name money then.
So how did Claire Lehman ended up here?
Uh,
willing to put your name
and faced all this stuff?
You know,
I,
I think I have bit more of a risk taking
streak in my nature and I don't feel
the same fear around social
disapproval as a lot of other people.
Um,
so I was a psychology graduate student
and I left my Grad program and before I
left I sort of, um, uh,
took a few risks during,
during my program and,
and we're sort of hung out to dry
by the university, so to speak.
Yeah. Do you want to give me
an example of one of those,
you sort of lit up when you said it?
Well,
I,
I complained about the amount of unpaid
work that psychology students had to do
in a clinic that was associated with the
university and they weren't happy with
that.
And I sort of received a bit of,
for sort of almost whistle blowing on the
amount of exploitation this clinic was
involved in.
So I've always said on the
first time I took a risk, um,
I've always taken risks when I've had
felt that my conscience demands that I do
so. And what led me to
create Colette was, um,
when I was a graduate student,
I was involved in a lot of online
discussions with academics in psychology.
And we had such fascinating,
interesting discussions
that were completely unlike
anything that you would see
in mainstream media.
And I thought, firstly,
there's a business opportunity here if
I can bring some of these conversations
to a market. And secondly, you know,
people need to know that there are,
there is scientific evidence and some of
these topics and mainstream journalists
on and neglecting to,
um,
inform readers about some of these
issues or some of some of this evidence.
Yeah. So I want to read the mission
statement from Colette Cause it's,
it's pretty freaking perfect.
Colette is a platform for free thought.
We respect ideas,
even dangerous ones.
We also believe that free expression and
the free exchange of ideas help human
societies flourish and progress.
Colette aims to provide a
platform for this exchange.
Everybody seems to be afraid of
dangerous ideas right now. Right?
I mean that's why this little crew of
people are together for whatever our
differences are.
Yeah.
I think that there's a,
there's been a conflation between
giving a platform or exploring ideas
and endorsing ideas and they're not the
same thing.
So I will publish stuff on Colette
that I don't necessarily agree with
politically.
Um,
I don't see the fact of publishing and,
uh,
necessarily as an endorsement. I also, um,
am very clear that I'm going
to make mistakes as an editor.
I'm Colette, we don't want to
make mistakes about accuracy.
And if we're ever called out for
publishing something that's not factually
correct, we will own up to
that mistake. But you know,
we're living in a time of
intense ideological flux
and to work out where we're
all going,
we need to be able to talk about things
freely and we need to be able to make
mistakes.
And I think make,
being able to make mistakes is a sign
of a healthy environment and it's a sign
of, you know, it's part of the
creative process. Yeah. Um, so the,
the, the, the warriors who
want to shut down debate,
who want to shut down free speech and um,
argue that giving a platform for
exploring dangerous ideas is equivalent to
endorsing them. They're basically
that you can't make a mistake.
And that's,
that's really scary because the only
way we move forward is to experiment,
test new ideas, see, see what works
and pick the best ones out of the,
the experimentation process
and move forward that way.
Yeah. So I want to discuss some
of the dangerous ideas. Yeah.
Or that your platform,
but it's interesting that you said
this thing about you don't mind making
mistakes because I feel
very much the same.
I will sit down with all sorts of people.
I've done it before,
people I agree with and disagree with
some people who I really don't like what
they're talking about.
But I try to give everybody a fair shake.
And what I'm noticing is
there's a tremendous amount
of pushback just on that.
That's what you're getting to.
Like the idea that a,
you can sit down with someone in separate,
a human being, mm. From their ideas,
but also that there's this sort of
secondary thing that I'm noticing.
And I think you, you get it too, just
from the articles you guys put out,
which is that if I don't ask the exact
question that someone wants me to ask or
I miss this or I word this this way,
but just this,
this army that doesn't feel that
organic to me is ready to pounce.
And I'm really trying
to work through that.
Like I don't spend too much
time thinking about it,
but it is a conscious thing like,
oh,
there's going to be this group of people
that no matter what I do and really
what they're trying to do
is chill everybody out so
that you'll only talk about
what they're comfortable with it.
Yeah. Well, there are,
there are people at the moment who feel
that all of the important questions have
been answered.
All of the important moral and
ethical dilemmas have an answer.
And that at this point in history,
everything's been worked out.
And anyone who's,
um,
exploring different ideas or is doubtful
about these moral issues is evil.
You're part of the Archi.
You're racist. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Um, so I come,
I come from a different approach where
like I don't know what's going on.
Like I, I'm trying to work it
out with other people and, um,
I want the freedom to be able to explore
in a weird way.
Does that get you the most hate?
Cause I think I really believe
that's where most people are.
I think that's why people
appreciate what I do here.
I'm just being open about my journey
and listening to people and learning and
all of that. Yeah, yeah. And that,
but that opens you up from hate,
from the both sides.
It's a lot easier to just stake out a
position and then you'll only get heat one
way. But when you're like, I am
going to hear both sides, you know,
it's why I love listening to Sam Harris
and Jordan Peterson debate. Yeah.
You know, the biggest existential
questions that there are. It's like, yeah,
it's like, if I've completely settled
my mind on this, I don't know.
I wouldn't be that impressed with
my thought process or something.
Yeah. Well, you know, I
don't get a lot of Hay. Um,
I certainly have Twitter trolls,
but,
well, wait til we post. Yeah.
Um, I sort of don't really notice
it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That's probably the most simple to
deal with this. All right. So let's,
let's talk about some of
those dangerous ideas.
What are some dangerous ideas that have
bubbled up from your writers that you've
had to think about or that you're,
you're focused on these days?
Yeah, so because my background
is in psychology, um,
we tackle issues that come
from the behavioral sciences.
So we've looked at sex differences,
um,
psychological sex differences
between men and women, um,
differences in interests in occupations.
Um,
so we've published some articles on
why there are fewer women in computer
science, for example. And, um,
we published a analysis of Jameson
DeMaurice Google memo written by four
different scientists who have
some expertise in that area. Uh,
we've published on intelligence Reese.
Well,
what were some of the results of,
yeah, well they, you know,
they basically said that something pretty
similar that he was in the ballpark in
terms of getting the science right and
his position is valid in terms of regular
scientific debate. There are observable
sex differences between men and women.
The differences in interests in
occupations is very robust and reliable.
So women are overwhelmingly interested
in occupations which have something to do
with people. So caring
professions, medicine, even law.
Whereas men have more
interest in occupations that
are to do with systems and
things.
So anything mechanical,
computer science and there's no,
there's no difference between the average
intelligence scores between men and
women.
And the evidence around differences
in verbal and mathematical ability is
somewhat mixed.
I mean you can,
you can have debates backwards and
forwards over the strengths of those
differences, but the difference
in interest is very robust.
Why are people so afraid of that?
Why is it that there is a set of people
out there right now that want us to act
to be all equal in their minds,
but it would actually force us to go
against nature? I mean that's what,
that's what this really is.
Well there is a fear that if
you acknowledge that there
are differences between
individuals or groups that you're
saying that one group is inferior.
So there's been a co like the idea that
we have to be the same to be equal has
been a very prevalent and strong idea.
I don't know who came where the
idea comes from. Right. But it's,
it's, um, it's dangerous
because if you, um,
if you argue that no true
or quality can be achieved,
unless we're all the same, then no, then
we can't have a quality. Yeah. However,
if you argue that no,
we're all morally equal and that
we deserve equal opportunity and,
uh, the equal, um, uh,
w we deserve equal opportunities to
live a happy, flourishing life. However,
there are differences between us.
Yeah. Then you can preserve that, um,
ethical principle.
So it's very problematic for people
who think that there can be no equality
between men and women unless we are
proven to be the same identical.
Um, because the evidence doesn't support
the idea that we're the same. Yeah.
What are, what are some of the other
dangerous ideas? Okay. So we've,
we're doing the dangerous role.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Um, we've published
work on intelligence research,
which is controversial. Uh,
we've published articles about
Harris Intelligence. Are you
talking about intelligence and race?
Um, cause this seems to be one that
people seem to be all that's, yeah,
that's a hugely controversial
issue. And uh, we've published, um,
we published a defense of the Charles
Murray's the bell curve because after he
had his conversation with Sam Harris,
vox came out and wrote a hit piece.
Yeah.
Or right at some,
some kind of article that misrepresented
what they talked about and the bell
curve.
And so we published a response
from Professor Richard Hire,
who's the editor of the
intelligence journal.
So he's a preeminent expert in this area.
And he defended Charles Murray's book
and defended the conversation that they
had and said,
this is a important issue.
It's scientifically valid and has
merit to talk about these issues.
And they got, they were, they
got the science right. Um,
so we,
we don't aim to be provocative for
the sake of just being inflammatory,
right?
We,
we have an objective where we want
to protect the scientists who have,
who are doing this work or who are
having these competent conversations.
We want us,
we want to protect the individuals who
are doing the knowledge production or the
research.
We want to protect them from the boxes
and the journalists who just want to
write hate pieces just to get the clicks.
So we have a,
a sort of a commitment to those people
who are doing risky work and need that
kind of protection.
You're going to my soft
spot today because as,
as we're taking this only as we're
taping this, only like an hour ago,
vox did a piece me about how I'm
part of the reactionary, right? Yeah.
Something and it's just like, you guys
are just awful. So in a weird way, your,
your,
your job in some respect has become
sort of like a force field to just allow
people to do the work that
they're supposed to be doing.
Yeah,
that's right.
Because universities for all sorts of
different reasons are neglecting their
duty to academic freedom.
Right.
And academic freedom is meant to exist
to protect scientists in particular who
are doing work,
which contradicts the religious orthodoxy
of the time or the moral orthodoxy in.
It's quite clear to me that there are
scientists doing work which challenges
politically correct dogmas and I don't
see universities doing a very good job at
protecting those scientists.
And so we feel like we can fill the gap.
Where, where do you think the gender
studies stuff fits into all this?
Because in a weird way it seems like it's
all being widdled down to that somehow
that now,
especially related to trans issues,
I was just talking to a fairly well
known public professor yesterday off the
record. Yeah. About how
he's going into his old,
even though he's factually
correct and it's calm, you know,
confident about his research.
He's going into old lesson plans to change
wording just because he doesn't want
to deal with the mob. So things that
were completely acceptable three,
four years ago is now having to edit out.
I mean that's, that's truly dangerous.
So what is going on with the gender
studies department and the rest of this?
It's all about
moving so fast. It's hard to really, um,
to analyze what's going on
when it's shifting so fast.
But certainly,
um,
many of the humanities departments took
a turn back in the 1970s and they took
the,
um,
took on these fashionable theories
such as poststructuralism and uh,
they, they rejected empirical methods. Um,
and so when the argument, if we were
trying to give them the credit yeah.
That they're due, at least in
the argument, if you're, yeah,
if you're rejecting empirical
science or verbal back,
what is your argument that leads you
there? Cause I looked at their watches.
Go next judge just sounds crazy,
but they obviously believe it.
So let's try to give the devil
his deal. Right? Yeah. So
postmodernists have a good point and
that is that we are all biased and a
scientist looking at an issue such as,
um,
sexuality has his or her own biases.
Right? And so the questions that
the scientists are asks when he, oh,
he or she is designing a survey
or designing a lab experiment,
I go in and have some bias embedded
within them that, so that's true.
And the postmodern has had that insight.
However,
the mistake they make is getting rid
of a PR empirical and objective methods
altogether and just saying, because
we're biased, what's the point? Right?
So they're doing like a
massive over correction.
Yes, yes. Yeah. When,
when what should be done is
acknowledging, yes, we all have our bias.
Um,
and if I'm a scientist designing a study,
I'm going to have my bias and it might
get embedded into the work that I'm doing.
However,
there are ways to correct that and
we want to improve our quantitative
methodologies in order to correct for
our own biases to the problem that the
postmodern is have is that they
say, well, the bias is there,
so let's put it all in the Bin and we're
just going to double down on the bias
and just talk about lived experience.
I mean that it's just taking the
completely the wrong direction.
Right? I mean it's quite literally the
reverse of the scientific method. Yeah,
so basically they're saying that
that bias is truth, right? I mean,
if you're saying bias that the
lived experience is what truth is,
then bias is truth. You know, I don't
know if you saw, but I did this,
this talk at University of New Hampshire
and this woman was yelling at me,
this trans woman calling me all right,
and all of this other
nuts and shouting me down.
I didn't realize this until
two months later or something,
but it turned out she was a gender
studies professor at the school. Yeah.
So you've got a gender studies professor
trying to shout down an invited speaker
while live tweeting that I'm all
right or whatever. And it's like,
I'm pretty sure maybe I'm
not right about everything.
I'll concede on that
even though I want it.
I said she should be treated with
respect and equality and all that.
But your biased that you're acting on
right now definitely is not closer to
truth than anything I was saying.
Yeah. So I, the way I think
of it ease that you know,
there is an objective reality and the way
we get to objective reality is through
the scientific method.
Um,
whereas postmodernists academics believe
a lot of them believe that reality's
created through language and discourse.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why they believe that words can be
violence.
Because if reality is actually created
through language and discourse and
there's, um, some kind of,
there's some toxic discourse than they
truly believe that reality can be changed
through words.
And so I think that's why they get so
upset about freedom of speech and just
having discussions because they truly
believe that words can change the way the
world is constructed.
Right? So for now they say
it's okay to punch a Nazi,
will they call everybody Nazis,
then it's okay to punch a Nazi and then
we can go however far down that road we
want to go. And then, yeah, then
you're completely condoning minds.
How concerned are you that these ideas
are going to trickle up higher into
places of power and that once they look,
we know they're in the media,
you've already mentioned VOCs
and a couple of those other, um,
but that once they're really in the
places of power in Australia or in the
states or wherever else,
that the screws are really gonna
be turned against us because yeah,
we're fighting for free speech.
Yeah.
I'm mostly be concerned about
these ideas getting into the law.
Traditionally the lore is a conservative
field and they are pretty good at
resisting political fads.
But you can see with the way that law
is taught in law schools at the moment
that there is critical legal studies
and often critical legal studies is a
mandatory component.
So they teach like the
feminist interpretation of
law and these approaches,
um, can undermine some of the basic, uh,
fundamentals and foundations of how
the law is meant to work. So I, yeah,
I am worried that there are
a lot of attacks on droop
due process at the moment,
freedom of speech and
the scientific method.
Those three things are foundations of
a civilized society and all of them are
being attacked at the moment.
Yeah. How does me to fit into
this because you've been,
you've been somewhat critical of that.
I think it gets all three of those
criteria that you just lay it out. Yeah.
Look,
you know,
obviously me to started as
a really legitimate and um,
power for movement in identifying the,
the predations that Harvey
Weinstein was engaged in. And,
and surely there are,
there have been many powerful men,
um,
in the last couple of decades working in
industries where there's a lot of young
women around and they have
positions of power and they,
they're able to exploit those positions.
But,
you know, I'm a young
woman myself, right? And I,
I don't see sexual
harassment, um, as being,
as pervasive as a lot of
people claim. And, uh,
I also think it's very dangerous to
make accusations against people publicly
because our reputations are so
valuable and so important that,
um, you know, we,
we need to respect other people's
ability to have, have their,
their reputation and um,
making accusations in public
sort of goes against my, um,
my feeling that
it feels vindictive to me
and it feels dangerous,
dangerous path to go down because for
every true accusation there is of sexual
harassment, there's going
to be someone who is, um,
you know,
there's,
there are going to be people who
have conflicts and then the conflict,
someone feels like they can resolve a
conflict through making an accusation of
sexual harassment.
And that's really scary.
We don't don't want people to resolve
their conflicts by making public
accusation.
Right. But I definitely think there's
a certain set of people that don't mind
collateral damage. Right? I mean that
seems to be what's happening right now.
And people you see this public, people
that are tweeting these kinds of things,
like it doesn't matter if you're in a
safe down a couple of ladies and people.
That's how dangerous this thing is.
That strikes me is far more dangerous
and I'm not belittling any of the actual
yeah. Things that some of
these women have gone through.
Yeah, it's scary. It's the, uh,
desire for collective punishment
and that collective punishment is,
is, is scary. It,
if you look at the Geneva Convention
that was established after World War II,
the UN declared collective
punishment a war crime.
So the idea is that when there is a
conflict between ethnic groups in certain
places, if, if one,
if some people are killed in that,
in a conflict, you can't then go on.
Wife had a village as a
collective collective,
retro retribution because that's
how these war crimes happen.
So now where this,
um,
lucky said this collateral damage,
this desire for collateral
damage is being normalized.
Like people don't seem to understand how
dangerous this is and how unjust it is.
What is, is part of the issue that
perhaps they do understand it,
but they so want to destroy the
system. This is, you know, I a,
I've been on tour with Jordan Peterson.
One of the things he's been
talking about a lot lately is yes,
you can acknowledge that we don't have
perfect systems and then there's perfect
systems are probably
impossible to ever get to.
But now we have this
new thing in the system,
which is let's just freaking destroy the
whole thing to build our perfect system.
Yeah. I think people don't
understand because, um,
we're not taught anymore. We're not
taught history properly. We're not,
we don't learn about human nature in
school and how it's almost an instinct to
want to desire retribution,
retribution and vindictive justice.
I think it's,
it's part of our nature is to want
to punish people and punish groups,
um,
and our institutions like a due process
and the presumption of innocence,
they sort of,
they go against our instincts,
but that's why they're
thankfully. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And I think what we're seeing is just
sort of like a regression back to our more
tribal instinctive nature.
And because our education system is so
atrophy [inaudible] young people aren't
being taught the value and the
fragility of these institutions,
how they came about, why they're so
important and why we must protect them.
So then I think there's just that basic
ignorance about why these institutions,
institutions exist in the first place
and then we're regressing to our more
primitive natures.
Yeah. How do you think social media fits
into this? Because it's, I did a video,
I think it's almost three years ago now,
that online culture is
becoming mainstream culture.
And I think that that's
what we're seeing now,
what used to be just relegated to the
meme makers and the pet bay people has now
just leaked everywhere.
And just everyone in,
in public is acting sort of as
their worst selves all the time.
And then that feeds all of this.
Let's either destroy the system or
let's ignore legitimate problems.
Well,
when you don't have proper law and order,
you do get mob justice in
vigilante justice in real life.
And you can see that throughout
history you've got, you get lynchings.
Um, you get pogroms, um,
you get groups like mobs of people going
and attacking an individual who they
think is guilty of like a sex crime or
some other crime and killing the person.
So,
and then what happened was,
is we develop legal and social norms that
stopped that kind of vigilante justice
from taking place. And if you
are a vigilante, you can just,
you can get in trouble with the law.
And then we've developed social norms
that prevent people from just forming mobs
and going attacking people in the street.
But social media is this
new technology and we don't,
haven't developed any of the
legal or social norms yet.
And so it's brought back
this mobbing behavior,
which is part of our nature.
It's brought it back.
But we haven't yet developed any of the
norms to sort of suppress it or mitigate
against it. Yeah. And I think we
eventually will develop these norms,
but it's gonna take awhile and there's
going to be a fee innocent people sort of
metaphorically lynched in the process.
Yeah. So that's actually an interesting
segue to something that's been on my mind
lately. So, you know,
Alex Jones got booted from Twitter
and Youtube and Facebook or whatever.
I don't even want to talk about any
of the things that he talks about.
It does not matter,
but,
but these tech companies basically decided
that this one guy is too dangerous.
You know, Farah can can be on
here and Hamas, whoever you,
whoever else you want to pick that you
don't like can be on here. But this guy,
you know, even paypal took
them out last week. Um,
do you think that the free speech
crew for getting his ideas,
do you think we should have offered
a better defense of why this person,
boat person should be allowed
to use these things? I mean,
should the guy be allowed to make
a phone call? Should he allow it?
Should he be allowed to have
running water at his house? Yeah.
Where do we draw the lines for this?
Yeah. Well I think these tools, uh,
that we use such as payment processing
and social media such as Twitter,
the instant messaging, the, the tools,
and they should be treated as,
as such,
like having electricity or water.
And um,
so you believe there are public
good, basically the same. Yeah.
Getting water to your house, getting
the phone line connected to your house.
Yeah. And, and they
shouldn't be politicized.
And as soon as you politicize these tools,
then it's,
there's a slippery slope and you know,
then there's going to be arguments
about who do we band next,
what standards do we want to
sit and that kind of thing.
And in the context of Alex Jones, I, I,
I think there's probably more to the
story that the public is aware of,
so I don't want to comment
on him specifically.
Yeah. And I don't want
to make it a bit, yeah,
just the general idea that a digital
assassination can occur because we're all
agreeing to terms of services that I'm
not sitting around with a lawyer every
time I click except to the new service.
Yeah.
And that eventually you could move
on anybody, you know what I mean?
We know the way these ideas work.
You don't get one person and then suddenly
be like, oh well we're good to go.
It's like who do you get neck?
Yeah. And the PA, the payment
processing is, is scary. I mean,
the idea that that should be
politicized is just, that is crazy.
Yeah. Hmm. So what do you
think the solution is? I mean,
I think you probably know my, my solution
is that we need more competition,
but I'm,
I'm really understanding of big counter
to that because it's like where is the
county?
Where is it?
Yeah. No, look, I don't have the answer.
And I tend towards being, um, uh,
economically liberal. However,
some of these tools, as you said,
are public goods and perhaps need to be
thought of as public widget rather than
rather than private. And
um, you know, I'm not,
I'm open to ideas and regulation,
government intervention and um,
and I'm also open to ideas about breaking
up some of the monopolies because we,
competition would be lovely,
but it's a bit difficult at the moment
because some of these companies have
gotten monopolies in lots of different
verticals. So Google for example,
has the search engine monopoly they've
got that almost got the advertising
monopoly, so they're leveraging their
monopoly in one area into others.
And that that just shuts down competition.
Yeah. Do you think it's even something
a little more perverse than that,
which is that, you know, look,
there's obviously I'm not a
blow the lid on anything here.
There's obviously tons of discussions
with all sorts of people about how do we
compete with youtube or how do we
compete with any of these things? Yeah.
But I think partly what's happening,
it's not just people who are going there,
this,
this big monolith.
I think people are actually genuinely
afraid of what it means to go up against
them. It's not like it's going to just
be a hard work situation. It's like,
what does it actually mean
to go up against the world's
information leader, come
compete against the monopoly.
That's the definition of a monopoly.
There's no competition.
And these,
some of these companies are monopolies
and they have captured the market so
effectively that you
cannot compete with them.
And so we either have to think about
regulating them so that they're free and
open to everybody or,
um,
breaking up their
ability to control the
market. I mean, yeah. Yeah.
This is the tough part for the Libertarian
Board. He was like, no, don't do it yet.
I do send some being pinned into,
yeah, that, that kind of answer
[inaudible].